afternoon oh I'm with my good friend
Chris for game 15 to have a look hi
Chris yeah hi we're looking at the third
tiebreak game now and yeah the important
thing here is um yeah that girl found
lost game two in this tie break or game
14 if you count it all together and he's
got the white pieces and this is
basically the Sun yeah almost last
chance to do something in the match yeah
it's a difficult with black if white
only needs to draw so this was basically
no one ever time so yeah let's see what
happens Saudi fall from your fan playing
white and then we see d5 and a repeat of
the Slav defense yeah but we already
have a new oh yes and your new thing
here because girl from played Knight f3
III and not this night c 3 III move
autumn oh yes and this is this is a
somewhat different because this can lead
to slightly slightly different positions
if we look at this on Knight f6 III it's
what Gavin played we already had the
position a couple of times with Knight
c3 instead of Knight f3 the different
series of black now wants to get into
this a six-time position so if he goes e
6 cm then white has some additional
options compared to the position with
the knight on c3 because he can play
moves like Bishop d3 here also on b3 and
the difference is if black now wants to
get a set up on similar to a to go to
the games before like this year then
white actually manages to to get quite a
nice setup let's say this
stuff oh yeah why they get this night on
if I this is a bit in a in actual to
black black Museum just to show the idea
this is the idea to keep the night back
on be one to have this control over a
five cool so I'm the c6 move it's okay
for black but it is just a different
position so I think the main move here
for black even is c5 so I'm just just to
take this back oh I think I made a mess
here okay what I what I wanted to say is
oops 6likes best move is maybe c5 about
this is a completely different position
than the ones we got before usually some
positions were all pieces stay on the
board so it's a good fighting choice so
e6 wasn't played but you she went you
should f5 right which is also by father
made wolf and this is some this leads
down to a very very well-known
theoretical line like go see six here
and then not H for this is another point
of quite smooth what he wants to get
this LightSquared bishop so we will get
the disappear yeah and okay it's not the
most impressive you should pay on the
first because the Gypsy one is not
terribly strong but it's something to
play for in the long run um a black now
as numerous possibilities you can
basically play all we should moves and
also Bishop g4 busy forearms on all
normal um I think I none played the most
straightforward way just Bishop 36 and
why took hear you and it's all all very
very normal this case castles he
actually is an interesting move black
would try here to launch some attack on
the H file yeah it looks looks
potentially kind of dangerous this this
nitrile and yeah yeah funny enough this
this was played on in a game Carlton was
asked elephant ghettofied that's black
so reversed roles and girlfriend
actually in this game you think it was
Tommy Memorial last year not quite sure
but I think Tom memorial in this game
gelfand actually went for this age file
a check card long but at the end was all
calculated by Magnus is not the worst
calculator ever know that was good a
good attacking effort though boy go yeah
yeah dad was I was a very cool fighting
game but of course this she is more into
a solid play year so you just 56 first
then aged three hassles all very very
normal moves yeah and I think the same
is all quite understandable but now
comes really am the first very crucial
point of the game um young as almond
said afterwards he just had a blackout
in this position and simply forgot about
the c5 possibility played Roxy ATM oh
this is actually major blunder already
yeah it's a problem um I mean the thing
is if I think what what black intended
to do is to take on c4 and then maybe
play at some point 45 and he wanted his
rook opposite widescreen but as I'm on
set he sort of forgot about this
possibility which is coming right now
which is C 5 and this is it's rather
strong in this position yeah I guess is
it because this Brooks an automatic
ponme this roots a target potentially
for a bishop on ie6 the hoist yourself
and also this summer weakens a seven the
stroke on c8 so right so cool
configuration is somewhat this somewhat
unlucky for for black right um so just
just make like because what we're about
to see is a b4 b5 are taking
where that Brooke will be a target on
this diagonal so that's quite amazing
how a little a little it'll in accuracy
can lead to a disaster and chess
actually yeah it gets very it gets very
am uncomfortable now for black mmm-hmm
so I think you went to push it all the
way back and then very important of
course a form this is so absolutely
necessary if I wouldn't have this
possibility now black would be able to
play you fire crews yes lock the only if
I'm first then do this attack yeah yeah
yeah but to us if this one would would
be a blitz game yeah and I would have
have like here maybe I would even
consider playing you five really cuz it
you think there's a vacuum I suppose all
these poor moves alright so maybe maybe
some stuff maybe it's completely crazy
i'm just-just will just want to put it
on it is crazy yeah but just to put it
on the board but this is suitable i
think for some offend blitz game oh yes
sorry this Tiger Team you might use that
be sure that that looks dangerous then
yeah no it'sit's thinking if it weren't
for G fool maybe yeah maybe maybe stuff
like this gee it's not it's not complete
completely helpless but yeah this holds
comfortably so you can add you form
maybe yeah it's easiest if you don't
have an immediate check it so it's
difficult okay was just a fun suggestion
more suitable for ya some lesson for one
game okay but but but Vichy of course
realized immediately that that he's in
danger now and immediately try to get
some some counter play going so what did
you play a book and I to ehm no I i yes
right yeah now we saw I'm be force this
this kind of attack on the queenside is
quite a factor here because it's got on
target the bishops now also tied that
has got very few squares and what was
very importantly if you look at like
on on configuration here this response
this is the case where this this WG porn
here it isn't the weakness in terms of
that it can be attacked and one but it
is a weakness as it makes black pawn
structure very am very inflexible what
you would like to do is in this position
play 45 wrong but he cannot do this
because f6 would just leave this g6 pawn
hanging of course this this is the
problem if it if they would imagine this
position let's say with the pond on the
g7 porn on age seven yeah yeah like just
played the dike just having played g6
then you could play for f6 and e5 and
would have I think I'm not sure decent
hard to play good counter play whatever
but you would have a plan to open up the
center you know encountered wide and so
we just cannot move f6e em and what you
did is actually the only way to open up
anything in this position you went for
f5 and then g5 and this also i think
confuses the position the most oops i
should turn this off of it confuses the
position the most gem and otherwise he
wouldn't have any play at all and so at
least it was a bit a bit confusing for
the white player so yeah I think we're
def five here f ing fourth everything
else yes yes the most logical trying I
actually g5 first no actually played g5
first not f5 really really what we're
calling to this yeah okay g5 first yeah
whatever it's quite it's quite quite the
same idea you know so g5 I know I think
quite prepared b5 further yeah now if
I've okay so um ok so this Bishop is
struggling to to break out at the moment
I will now we see be five though the
queen size really crashing through quite
quickly yeah just assault
this configuration is just it's just
awful for like so he takes on there
Elise is on double de spawns but in the
process now why it's got this in frontal
pressure as well yeah okay well I can
always stick something into your phone
no you won't ever lose six is not to eat
corn really right due to this thing but
the bleachers just this configuration on
the queenside with rock on CH you
shouldn't be eight and we will see
immediately yeah out how terrible this
this becomes yeah so he brought the c8
night back into into play yeah and now
why takes on c6 and please [ __ ] abates
a6 and very very good yeah very
embarrassing for black now in this
position what we saw was Brooke c7 which
looks very awkward for the bishop but
what if the rook if the rook didn't
protect b7 I suppose rook b7 so say rook
d8 is it Organa seven I just I just
thought Bishop e7 and I wonder win c6
and to win the game alright Bishop be
something isn't it i'm not sure but this
would be my first I'm always the
primitive guy that's the good point
about c6 even Bella Ruby's a little by
do anything but but but what would wait
wait a second what about 95 m this could
be a very very annoying idea let's say
this kind of stuff what are you doing
now moving the King up lady form blimey
oh la mia counter pie very very very
strange stuff happening that suddenly is
breaking out so maybe we should be seven
is so it's not good after all climbing
home okay so let's let's let's go back a
couple of moves so maybe Bishop e7 isn't
so great but um what what else yeah rook
b7 suddenly not bad but i would like to
win c6 really the spawn is I mean how
should black protect this pawn it's very
difficult to see because he cannot move
this
m night somewhere and yeah all pieces
are just it's it's it's it's tragic
comical I love the word in English but
it looks it looks strange but what
what's actually a good movie is this
year the same thing actually I was just
wondering about route b7 Queen I 42
first pin that night and then with Queen
I for maybe yeah maybe but if you look
at this move it just protects everything
here all right all 95 and I'm just
reddening should be 7 11 else are you
doing to ya to prevent this you cannot
you don't have a move there's no chip
that's like a cheapo isn't it this night
sight see file on the style is a little
bit cheaper yeah yeah yeah but important
very very important yeah like wants to
save c6 now he needs to go something
like this year and this looks like no
it's not much fun this this kind of
stuff no it's terrible a 786 and black
has absolutely nothing here yeah yeah
it's just it's just a terrible position
right so yeah I guess I guess also I I
think also an unwanted to play at least
quickly 22 ah let's go back Scott I
think there's another idea cheeky idea
behind Roxy 7 to be honest yeah ok which
is the idea of you know later he wants
to play g5 maybe you know if he can
unravel these nights wants to swing the
rock over yeah absolutely valid point
but that's quite ambitious so Bishop e3
ok let God's against night c 5s isn't it
on that that cheap ugg bit 95 is games
again some plates completes development
and looks very very nice right yeah for
terrible position but one thing if you
look you look at the times here it just
revert one move just one move mmm look
here girlfriend who had used almost
eight minutes here seven to eight
minutes and wish she was almost on 25
minutes so
he played really for his standards
terribly but he was quick he was quick
and he kept on playing quick moves here
while girlfriend was spending lots of
time that's just yeah I've just I've
just realized sometimes we get a glimpse
a very high-class place like and and and
Aronian recently what would they do in
Dutch Stonewall porn structures not that
they ever play the Dutch Stonewall but
you get answers don't you was because
Aronian also had a Dutch stone wall
structure against girlfriend recently in
one that game was a brilliant game do
you remember that yeah very nice very
nice game but you don't usually catch
them with this structure because this is
a very fixed structure isn't it this
this pawn structure and you've weakened
the dark squares very committed on dark
square weaknesses yeah I think okay this
is not really a typical song one year
but this dis opening is I think I'm very
much underestimated form for let's say
player below below world-class level so
for for international masters and then
below it's just a fine opening for black
book scramble you are think so I my
goodness whole George who plays it with
great success at Salman's yes he he
plays the docs tomo yeah yeah it's not a
bad choice at all you've got lots of
interesting points going for us black
you've got a very nice so corns in the
center and it's a very good opening
against tactical players hmm if you get
some summer corn into a sir just
calculating lines but doesn't really
understand much about chess it's a great
opening hmm because you need to really
play strategically fine and it's
difficult to do so so it's not not that
bad but we're getting really far away
yeah acacia myself cable I don't play 90
form now repeat so very powerful
doubling of rooks and simple just
targeting this be aids very simple
Chesser this route be too yeah blesses
only far he's got to play with at the
moment anyway so he just needs to UM
plan
file if he doubles out Brooks there's
all sorts of nasties but g5 trying to
generate a counter play now we see just
the doubling of rooks and of course
black can't take here would be a total
disaster on v8 yeah um also he did take
part of me oh yeah they can play a five
yeah what can you do it don't really
have anything but do you it's just it's
just it's just terrible yeah of course
he did play this cuz of e5 but as we see
there is a bit of a snag with all this
after a five there's a huge snag coming
up in this position now you don't want
to take with the pawn because c5 will
drop with check and that will be quite
embarrassing so he takes with the bishop
yeah and after night takes he routinely
um plays um a huge mistake here um I
wonder if actually should we give it a
test two are youtubers if we give
everyone on YouTube ten seconds here
what would you play here as white ten
seconds starting from now the best move
to play as white in your opinion as I
move 26 okay
now in in the game I rook takes be eight
was played now presumably okay okay deep
Dee takes d5 is a total disaster isn't
that Queen to e5 check yeah yeah black
and begging the win CS yeah so um he
didn't really consider Knight takes e4
so in principle Knight takes e4 would
seem to liberate for example this black
rook on the F file and give black a
signal huge position but the thing is
the thing is it's worth doing that here
so what does black do here apart from F
takes e4 um there's not much is that if
he moves the night then night d 6 is
very painful very painful yeah now this
this this rook takes v8 is next what you
got do about b8 it's also not Adam so it
was a little disaster yeah you just lost
på den you lose all everything falls
apart yeah 94 sir was just winning the
game was absolutely winning the game
yeah he played rook takes be 8 which is
actually getting rid of I'm
unfortunately getting rid of blacks
problem piece that's like probably it's
really hard to tell what he what what
what he what he overlooked here what I
mean that takes he falls strategically
it's a terrible move but it just went
sappy is so certificate of EFT I see for
liberating the rook yeah but you just
need to see that after detects e5 black
cannot save piayed it's really strange
that you didn't see this maybe and of
course Geffen realized that he was
winning in this position there's no no
doubt yeah and maybe he's somewhat is
somehow had a blackout and somehow
couldn't believe that he was winning
after 20 moves it's not like that you
would expect this to happen I'm not I'm
not sure hard to tell it's not it's not
difficult for those kind of players yes
to spot this I think in the Blitz game
or whatever they would spot this he
would spot this almost all the time but
how do you think so in this position
Black is helpless for that b8 bishop but
in a way it looks as though all of
whites play is is designed to win b8 and
it's strange unfortunately at the climax
of where he could have tactically 1ba
all the positional lead-up was just
wasted you know locking in the bishop
peeling open heavy fall it was all
wasted it's hard to tell that's very
hard to tell and the thing is if you
look at the game white was also great in
the game so maybe he beforehand just
this happens to me also quite often if I
beforehand calculate some line and and I
think I don't want to spend so much time
and so on then I just played the line I
get calculated before if it is good for
me of course and then I might miss some
some far stronger move it's just
speculation here because if you look at
the game it was also very nice for white
but it's not outright winning yeah which
after he takes after 94 I think that
would have played like three or four
moves and then black designs and i'm not
sure what happens in the last game this
isn't the nice thing the nicest thing to
happen to you after you just one game to
end got into the lead like like on RT
and then you loosen 25 moves me yes but
some believe was just for you know Alan
did seem okay okay very lucky that rook
takes b8 was played here so now okay
here's a pawn down but he's got fighting
chances yeah it's not lost and I've lost
immediately right on so Knight takes e4
and our technical move Queen after using
that pin if it were tricky maybe Queen
after using the pin ok so the bishop
though is not going to be able to help
defend these pawns on dark squares so
these pawns could be vulnerable later
which will give black chances Queen g7
okay so after King h2 now was played and
the rooks double which looks nice Queen
G free
so here I actually predicted this move
this move coming up that he wants to
sort of um okay you get pressure on d4
but it's not going to be with his Queen
it's going to be with this night soon
now off yes next move he plays Knight f4
because the night can come either here
or potentially here if it wasn't with
bishop yeah the missile in this
situation on i-26 attacks defined you
cannot protect it easily with some some
minor piece you don't want to protect it
passively with your rook so yeah this is
some counter plane I think my white
might still be better but it's not at
all easy to play in and it's also a
little bit of this typical situation if
you're the lower the time the the more
trickier the night gets in comparison to
the bishop yes it's a it's just it's
just like this it may mean the bishop is
the stronger Pete is still here on like
this Bishop e7 ideas at some point just
picking up all those pawns but it's a
notoriously tricky to play you know this
and I think Gavin spend lots of time
here hmm come up with xmas so he had 720
about oh my god are you serious he spent
about five minutes there on rook be free
ya on that one move as we just seen it's
720 to 145 according to this these relay
times which were proxima so he's really
getting down the clock here after rook
be free yeah I think I remember thinking
he was a goner actually just just from
the clock situation so the Queen's came
off check check but now this night e 6
will be helping black put pressure on
white we've also got a dangerous porn
and dangerous possession of the F file
which could be useful so I Apple I
fancied black hair when I was looking on
the live relay at the time I fancied
blacks chances because the clock
situation yeah I think from practical
point of view I was also quite
optimistic for black
here it's a it's not easy to play at all
and you can easily imagine that what
might lose tafolla at some point and
then then he's maybe just lost because
his pawns are just just more advanced
than why it's gah form these points are
just back home and he would lose before
then the youporn can be very dangerous
and he point is dangerous alone yeah
even with geforce still alive me and
black it's not difficult to play nine
invade on f 2 and so on yeah I'm you're
right i'm gavin did it did a good job
here to really preserve something here
some which was not much on the clock
yeah amazing Bishop e2 Bishop g4 so this
is this is a nice maneuver so his kicks
that night away from attacking d 4 which
means his rook can now free to move and
start counter-attacking then we saw
Brooke f7 defending against seven Brooke
be eight okay so after work v8 he's
offering for a moment 82 but then Brooke
CA is on the cards but yeah why just sir
really going far for car to play here
yeah so um he tries to also maybe get
some attack iridium next king and III
even this look really dangerous because
of this g2 dropping off so there's a
question that White's King safety so III
is a bit radical though but I don't know
if there's anything better night tastes
no there isn't night there isn't any
anything immediately that easy now that
bishops doing a good job and that
diagonal ready isn't that cutting like
working yeah it keeps some skips class
away from from the light and also at
some point my plate Bishop d7 takes c6
if the time is right for this standard
white just as counter play against the
c6 porn yeah and a move like rook f6 is
really
it may be good but it's also looks kind
of passive to just defend this pawn and
it looks dangerous here you three looks
dangerous for for white yeah I also
would have considered this surely so he
plays III distracting the rook away from
the fence of g2 so roof leaks due to
check and then the route goes to attack
default yeah and this really is some
nice piece of calculation by my
girlfriend really to learn that he
allowed all this because it looks
dangerous yeah White's King being cut
off cut off on the first rank yeah but
there's simply no no mate coming up if
you think about most like would be seven
and so on i think this is the issue here
right yeah if I think it just took on c6
know right so it just takes some c6 now
night Lisa's having rook b7 it's too
risky isn't it if root be some we got
things like um Bishop f5 check yeah I
see that defends immediately the beach n
square doesn't it as well as meaning
rookie free is more dangerous um yeah
maybe a gag but also 96 looks looks
quite nice what you played yeah now this
way you just come would be one so you're
not not getting mated 96 a fun movie yes
96 threatens immediately am item one so
the night isn't pre to all three pieces
here but this mating 14 it has to be
done something about so white here
facially this mate while he plays rook
have free and then we see the rooks /
Brooks coming off and then
simplification Knight takes d4 but
Allen's hugely confident here perhaps
overly confident in this position that
he's going to be okay because okay he
gets the rook behind the porn
but to some commentators what was
occurring and now very soon he's got
optimism he can draw this position but I
what was surprising a lot of context was
this next move here night FG check that
was adults a surprise to many because
you know it doesn't look like a routine
draw the zip this position no um as odd
I'm just thinking what happens watch
what happens on 96 on my e6 in this
position yeah and set off what what
happens it's a good question
you just get c5 I think I'm very hard to
imagine that you would lose this yeah
because the bishops not on the right
color for this destination yeah also I
wonder night and say is this isn't this
weird I mean okay you always got the the
imminent danger here in this kind of
kind of position if you look at this TR
ok seven and then let's say it takes I'm
not sure which piece um you somehow adds
a slight danger here that at some point
you might need to sacrifice a night
against the porn and then you need to
defend rook and Bishop wear this look
which is a draw but it's not actually
fun to play not sure or maybe just
islands some are panicked and had that
some wrong idea about the rook endgame
it might send me a draw but it's a makes
life I think more difficult than the
necessary really hold on sir what about
this move rook c6 just to get rook g6 in
as any interest so yeah 95 check check
you know to f4 I can I can make this
event not much another check here you're
just it's just nothing mmm don't even
windy a pawn him no yeah this I pool hot
be enough is that for the side pool now
push up and rock alone really everybody
can get you get you close to meet here
yeah this looks rather simple yeah you
like it just you just you just you just
had some some wrong idea about the
Rogaine am I guess yeah that's
interesting yet so it seems as oh maybe
he was mega confident about this other
other why they're just not a free I
think that's probably yeah that's
probably why everyone was surprised I
think why not have free then maybe it
was to do with 96 as well being being
available because this this real
component in
um okay he was he was confident perhaps
it was a dead draw but son the King
needs to go quite far over here to win
this pawn and then this porn is
potentially dangerous in theory and
we're out to see if you it'd be bad but
it's ready to return a couple of balls
three instead of kicking a farm I can
play at this one also and this is also
any media draw ripe threatening rook
hate free so if check you just you
should go back then you have to the
fence c5 again you're on right this is
just a drop h-hold use of King g4 so
yeah blimey so maybe that's so something
maybe was she was worried that um the
king is too far away from from the sea
porn at some point but it's it's just a
draw yeah I thought it was a draw anyway
yeah but maybe it simply it simply
wasn't so white white had a chance some
moves later so Brooksie ight now the
Kings going for that that see porn okay
but it's gone some distance away and it
looks as though I fought it was just
really drawn I was convinced you know
that oh you know if you'd leave white
with just the rooks porn it's going to
be easier to draw but um it wasn't quite
like that because here okay the rooks
bonus is temporarily protected of rookie
chains and the King has to go even
further if it bonds the munch it now so
here is 0 cringe a crunch position at
move 59 do you find sometimes there's
almost like peer pressure and endings as
though everyone thinks they've got a
sort of embarrassment about their own
end gain knowledge and they go with the
flow all about
something being clearly drawn when in
the particular position it might not be
you ever get that feeling that it really
depends on the position everyone thinks
they have this knowledge of n games
which which is comprehensive you think
everyone believes us I'm not quite sure
I know from from from my own experience
that they're quite lots of exceptions
and special positions and whatever and I
really don't don't know a lot of them
and I'm cross no need to calculate a lot
on at the board in those kind of end
games and um I think it's often much
more difficult than it looks at first
yeah so um I think it was also you also
a matter of time here because some girl
phone was down to a couple of seconds he
I think it was a lot lower on time than
this that is suggested here with this
one minute 7 which is displayed here I
think he was down two seconds right so
it seems he played in an accurate move
here apparently there's a really strong
move here I wonder if I youtubers can
guess it a very strong move found out
later if we give you 10 seconds um or
okay the move played was actually rook
h7 but apparently I we leave kingi free
stronger yeah yet this is anas winning
and it is i think maybe is a case form
where one person wants to be too clever
or something or you will look something
simple because what this is just a
normal move here who gauge seven looks
like i had brilliant or just stupid and
in this case it was stupid because you
just need to advance with your king here
and it's um it's ghost impossible to
they heard then it's impossible to
defend so what should like do here maybe
we should put put some new moves on the
board so let's say black advance which
is king right yeah so you just just just
to show him no no no
I'm not kinky for knocking before you
can you can immediately go here and this
is immediately over why is that bad
cause kingi for because it went
immediately oh because you're writing
about your fretting a major in broke I a
rock yet okay a dead over because you
got the check if ya Paul I've got always
this chick motive so this one's a
meeting of course yeah this is the
problem with leg trying to to advance
his King so and if King is sick so you
get the check here rookie a check yeah
and then a chain so this King is
actually going to be victimized in
relation to this porn by force yeah
exactly so it's all it's the same with
King g6 here which also wins immediately
you don't even need the King here so
like that cannot advance as king so this
leaves me basically was roop h1 and then
I just I just the ones with the King
like still cannot move the song king so
it's just like this would use to to
capture checks here yeah and exactly and
we get this position yeah and then we
build a sort of bridge with rook g8 um
yeah okay then let's say king here woof
g8 groups look somewhere I'm not sure
but it may be too ice as one tripadvisor
okay but page one it doesn't doesn't
matter much I can also go here and then
you just go back and then King g7 and
the h points is running cool so it's
it's it's it's really it's completely
it's really simple and it's just he must
have overlooked something something
simple here of course is lots of
pressure and so on but not terribly
difficult now some believable isn't it
the second chance to win this game it's
like mid this game is missed
opportunities isn't that yeah sure sure
I mean it's easy to anyone same
retrospect though retrospect is the most
powerful grandmaster going I think
yeah course in many autumn if you if you
you need to be M um it here if you i
watch the livestream here comment
livestream with comentary by a Peter
Svidler and as it unfolded of course
they only they played very quickly
careful because it didn't have much time
and Alan because he wanted to keep the
pressure on and he also couldn't tell
immediately like in g three wins and
they he and also the Russian commentator
saw this pretty quickly after afterwards
after yeah but it's not like they see it
in like two seconds so or anything but
yeah but why wine is King Geoffrey play
a pivotal role in that that you can't
play h 7 immediately then what wise King
Geoffrey such a key to the position here
you need you need to have the
opportunity to go with the King to age
70 might play except now yeah let's
let's say you play at seven yeah yeah so
then I just stay you just stay yeah and
because one way if you if you I need to
stay on gee maybe seven with my king
well now i cannot King Geoffrey here and
I can't move the rooms at the point I
can't move the rock now and just I'm
just staying here isn't that absolutely
amazing that such a tiny difference has
gigantic proportions behind it yeah this
is rook endgames the rootstock now and
and the king yeah and i can i can just
stay on a 737 and then i drop to h1 and
give checks from the back you just give
chase so there's no there's no way
building a bridge here now no I can't
you can just I can just check I can Asia
I can even stay on the edge farm it's it
doesn't matter it's amazing isn't it
haha its answer it's absolutely brutal
isn't it tragic look this is this is but
this is very important to know that it's
it's really a good idea to play move
like age seven
um because you often need this the
square for the king so okay you should
play age seven if it wins it wins
immediately like in this position we as
we saw if that goes like he I play age 7
and you just windy and calculated like
it's a to move on yeah but strategically
speaking this is not a good move very
often you need this miss Claire for the
king but ok here it wins immediately
because black played the bad move King
King to do six yeah it's all decided
here by time time management I think
give him three minutes on the clock and
he never play rock 87 unbelievable I
mean it's unbelievable i find that
finesse is here I've wasn't has this
great master cool floor was it he was
good at endings as well as Rubenstein
and they were brilliant at rub Paul
anything's I mean Rubenstein was most
famous wasn't he foot for endings yeah
Rubenstein sir maybe the the best stroke
and can play ever or at least let's say
he had really a huge amount of very
instructive for examples very nicely
I'll played people from like let's say
minimum advantages and he just played
model games out of this hmm so it's very
useful to study hmm but let's say this
about this position here for instance is
this kind of basic position you can
without any knowledge just calculate at
the board and see that how it wins but
it's not easy to do so in one minute or
30 seconds so what what to say I think
Ian should should manage in one minute
but okay it's a it's not like some some
weekend tournament anyway it's a some
some huge pressure there and somehow the
quad she didn't didn't really a god
bettered you to go all this pressure it
was very of course very thrilling to
watch but really lots of lots of
mistakes made yeah so I'm really a huge
chance for girlfriend or not not one
chance like a ton of chances to to to
defend to to win here and get you a tie
here
match so now as king is coming to the
rescue after King these six is very
different with the King coming to the
rescue now yeah the rook on age seven is
just just terrible and I'll because you
don't have little circles age 7 and this
checks so black and just advance King
now and in fact here they drew did they
King d6 in the game yeah yeah black a
black and just just advance as king
edits over amazing amazing it's just
it's brutal charity really is in all
phases absolutely brutal game all right
listen I don't know if we should do a
quick overview in summary showy let's do
a quick over here summary um yeah okay
let's ditch Esther do this cookie so a
slob of a difference with my f free
early on big difference and it seems
Anand slipped up early on this is very
theoretical path but um he seems to be
slipping up with routine move here
coming up rook c8 which Nathan but to
take on unsafe on yeah so this makes the
whole plan of peeling open the queenside
much more effective with that Bishop
being a target on be aids if I've been
clamped down on by white kind of Roxy
vine but against thief I've made worse
by the double porns which make it harder
for black to play for f6 and e5 so he
plays for f5 and g5g five first then f5
trying to generate some can't play he
plays this defensive move curiously rook
c7 which defends it seems b7 but also
might have the idea of optimistically
game for an attack later but now soon
girlfriend mounts up the pressure on the
B file to be a everything seems geared
up for the b8 to be the prisoner of the
position and this a five we get this
first position after Knight takes e4
where a non intuitive sort of move
actually would end up winning material
by force namely night takes
efore here unfortunately this
non-intuitive move was not considered
too much and in fact instead rook takes
be a so a difference of between plus
free with Knight takes e4 and not point
6 according to engines so Knight takes
e4 wasn't played major opportunity
missed but still why it was the pawn up
but now black has some count play and he
doesn't even mind the Queen's coming off
because he can victimize the default
porn which the light square but can't
really check help defend too easily so
the pressure now on white especially
with clock pressure he still managed to
to fight here and infiltrates now of his
rook to come an attack c6 dropping a 2
in the process and even III doesn't
really help black watch and still Allen
was in a difficult position but he
missed a much clearer away there was a
mate fret there after 96 so we had
simplification here into a position
where an abscessed an opportunity for a
quite clear draw it seems coming up here
after this king h 2 nite e6 as chris
points out 96 and it looks as though
that's a clear draw but it's Ted Knight
f3 which maybe isn't as easy as
demonstrated while the game match the
well y know yeah you can King edge far
so would have drawn I'm sorry King h4
yes so maybe this is also a draw but
it's really yeah unito to really play
this now otherwise you'll get into
trouble yeah so we got into trouble with
King f4 and now we have this curious
precision of jealousy we're actually
that seat born is a major decoy in a way
but it needs a hyper precise move here
I'm not to play h7 but in this position
to play a king or locator and to play
kingi
free a major missed opportunity of the
game not taking g free but we've
retrospect the benefit of hindsight is a
wonderful thing a super grandmaster
that's never beasts in retrospect so so
here they drew okay I know if anything
else you want to say Chris them if we
just say comments or questions on both
our channels will both uploads this yeah
I guess yeah thanks for watching and I
hope you enjoyed this also there's a
nice little things about the end game at
the end are thinking about be helpful
yeah so I hope everyone got sleep on
that that's great okay thanks very much